[Musica]
che cos'è un idea
beh io potrei definire l'idea come un
meccanismo della mente umana atto a
riconfigurare gli elementi della propria
conoscenza in una veste originale oppure
più romanticamente parlando mi piace
pensare all'idea come a un isola del
tesoro da ricercare dopo una tratta in
acque inesplorate ed immensa perché di
fatto se l'isola del tesoro e l'idea
allora il viaggio verso la validazione
di quest'area in pratica non è altro che
un percorso di sperimentazione il mio
intervento oggi si intitola viaggio
nelle perigliose acque della
sperimentazione musicale
in altre parole parleremo di perigli che
in italiano moderno significa pericoli
ogni viaggio alla ventura che si
rispetti non può che iniziare da una
mappa del tesoro che tradizionalmente a
un punto di partenza una ics rossa a
indicare al tesoro e un percorso
tratteggiato che si snoda nella
pergamena
se ci pensate la visione l'idea non è
altro che una mappa ovvero avere
una fotografia chiara di dove si vuole
arrivare a parare sapere dove si parte e
poi iniziare a pianificare un percorso
che subirà dei vari cambiamenti di rotta
ma ci porterà verosimilmente
auspicabilmente alla meta di fatto una
volta che abbiamo pianificato il nostro
percorso
sappiamo chi siamo e dove vogliamo
andare non ci resta che metterci nelle
condizioni di raggiungere la nostra meta
e per fare questo dovremo arruolare un
equipaggio a rompere un equipaggio può
essere un'impresa facile o difficile in
virtù del capitano che che siete
se voi siete il capitano facoltoso che
può entrare nella taverna con due borse
di denaro sbattere sul tavole pagare i
marinai
beh molto probabilmente avrete la fila
di marinai che vorranno arruolarsi con
voi se parimenti siete il capitano che
ha già ottenuto tanti tesori e ha già
vinto diverse avventure
beh allora anche in questo caso avrete
fortuna
l'ipotesi un po più sfortunata diciamo è
quello in cui voi siate una sorta di
jack sparrow dei tempi moderni quindi un
capitare un po squattrinato dalla
reputazione fumosa
beh in questo caso è più difficile che
ai vostri marinai dovrete chiedere di
seguirvi sulla fiducia e per fare questo
dovrete essere molto bravi a prendere la
vostra visione metterla su pergamena e
mostrarla agli altri quindi avrete in
questo modo preso la visione l'avrete
resa un progetto comune
una volta preso il mare con il nostro a
chi paga dovremmo però fare attenzione
che a un certo punto parte di questo o
l'intero equipaggio non faccia
ammutinamento e l'ammutinamento può
avvenire per diverse ragioni
la principale è la frustrazione la
vostra idea il vostro progetto e lungo
da realizzare impiega settimane mesi
qualcuno potrebbe mollare la spugna
tanto più se gli orizzonti di successo
non sono ben definiti
oppure qualche capitano riesce a
cooptare i vostri marinai pagandole di
più o per ragioni familiari o anche per
ragioni strategiche perché di fatto
l'equipaggio non è composto soltanto
dagli stretti collaboratori ma da tutti
quegli intermediari che stanno tra voi
il vostro progetto la vostra canzone nel
mio caso è il vostro pubblico
l'idea deve essere comunicativa non
soltanto per gli utenti finali ma anche
per tutta la filiera che poi vi
accompagnerà agli utenti finali appunto
a me
diciamo che è capitata una situazione un
po di stallo mezzo ammutinamento da
parte di alcuni intermediari i media che
magari facendo parte alcuni giornalisti
di una vecchia guardia di una certa età
insomma pensarono che il mio progetto
che trattavasi di un app album ovvero la
prima licenza sia e per un album
divulgato sotto forma di applicazione
per telefonini e tra l'altro mixato in
3d audio per cuffie auricolari quindi
con diversi tratti di comunicazione
pensarono che il dover andare sullo
store digitale scaricare l'applicazione
sul telefonino installarla
inserire un jack di auricolari a
sentirsi un'ora un quarto di musica in
questa modalità diciamo che fosse un
pochino troppo laborioso e quindi nel
mare magnum dell'offerta musicale che
ogni giorno arriva sulle loro scrivanie
perdere tutto questo tempo per
un'emergenza era un abbraccio in un
attimino diciamo sconveniente e anche
come dargli torto
l'ammutinamento può fermare un progetto
nel mio caso non ha fermato ma può anche
arrivare a stoppare un avventura
tuttavia non è l'unico pericolo che si
può incontrare nel mare perché a un
certo punto potrebbe spuntare fuori la
famigerata bandiera nera con il teschio
dei pirati e qua c'è anche poco da fare
e metafore perché i pirati sono
tradizionalmente coloro i quali derubano
in questo caso derubano l'idea la
realizzano prima di voi e vi bruciano
ogni impatto di comunicazione per
difendersi dai pirati chiaramente la
grande arma è il riserbo chiedere
riserva voi stessi e al vostro gruppo
che negli anni di social media non è un
impresa facilissima
voi pensate quando stavo registrando in
sala teutonico e c'erano collaboratori
amici di collaboratori tutti con il
cellulare a filmare il robot a farsi se
il figlio dall'altra parte dire ragazzi
mi raccomando non postate nulla prima
che esca il progetto pd magari chiedendo
riserbo per anche un mese e mezzo e due
mesi addirittura una volta sopravvissuti
ai pirati
beh se la possibilità di incontrare un
altro pericoloso ostacolo
ovvero quando si naviga in acque
inesplorate senza riferimenti sulla
mappa sulla cartina
ci si può imbattere in quegli scogli
acuminati che sono sotto livello
dell'acqua nessuno sa che sono lì però
se si finisce contro la tua barchetta
cola a picco a livello tecnico
rappresenta un poco gli inconvenienti di
quei progetti pionieristici che essendo
tali non hanno una casistica di errore
alle spalle su cui basare le
contromisure
io personalmente mi sono fatto
terribilmente male con gli scogli
quando fui accettato da una trasmissione
televisiva internazionale in un altro
paese a esibirmi con un mio brano e con
lamma mia modalità di concerto del tempo
che era il 3d audio
quindi io avevo il mio ritorno in cuffia
il pubblico aveva delle cuffie wireless
io mi esibivo a questo microfono che è
un microfono binaurale dotato di due
padiglioni auricolari dove se cantavo
a sinistra l'ascoltatore aspettava
sinistra si cantava destra ascoltava
destra anche le cuffie si girava tutto
intorno
l'ascoltatore sentiva la mia voce gira
intorno alla testa
quindi per la prima volta un
presentatore avrebbe dovuto dire al
pubblico da casa
inserite le cuffie al televisore per
effetti 3d come al cinema quindi prove e
selezioni consapevolezza di avere un
numero che ci avrebbe portato avanti
perché era molto originale ha un primato
e soprattutto una consapevolezza
rafforzata dalla mattina dell'esibizione
quando abbiamo fatto le prove a teatro e
abbiamo avuto i complimenti della
produzione poi la tragedia
immaginatevi sono dietro le quinte
esco innanzi a me un teatro d'opera
pieno 3000 persona il presentatore le
luci la scenografia le telecamere quanto
di più emozionante ci possa essere il
mio momento le mie cuffie tengo la mia
carriera che può prendere il volo a
livello internazionale in mano
sostanzialmente e mi avvicino verso il
microfono e man mano che mi avvicino
sento una crescente distorsione in
cuffia e inizia a sudare freddo poi apro
la bocca per cantare e la mia voce esce
distorta con latenza ed effetti
stranissimi beh mi fermo chiedo il
cambio cuffia penso ma che sfiga proprio
le cuffie scariche arriva il
presentatore mi dà le sue cuffie mi
metto le cuffie il pubblico fa un
applauso di incoraggiamento e io zac
secondo
riprendo un'esibizione stessa identica
scena la mia voce ancora distorta neri
fermo un'altra volta
tolgo le cuffie altro cambio di cuffie
altro applauso io chiaramente
imbarazzatissimo alla terza volta portò
a conclusione esibizione che però deve
essere annullata per inconvenienti
tecnici né positiva né negativa
il giorno dopo io i miei collaboratori
prendiamo l'aereo torniamo a milano con
la coda tra le gambe totalmente
distrutti ma con informazioni importanti
cioè sulla nostra mappa si è accesa
un'area con degli scogli acuminati e
nella fattispecie di classi trattava poi
però se telecamere due grossi estetica
che erano state inserite in trasmissione
ma non delle prove
le telecamere con il loro segnale
avevano creato interferenza con l'apt
rientra li na che inondava l'audio alle
cuffie del tè la sala ivi comprese le
mie quelle del pubblico e le
informazioni importanti ma quanto sono
costate settimane di prove viaggi
selezioni litigi perché poi quando le
cose vanno male si finisce sempre per
mitigare ma
ambizioni sogni prospettive di cambio di
vita maturata in poche settimane e
bruciate in pochi secondi di esibizione
ma soprattutto una figura dinanzi a
tremila persone di un teatro che non
erano tenuti a sapere il perché
l'esibizione fosse fallita perché quando
fallisce qualche cosa c'è la tua faccia
e il pubblico e non ci sono scusanti
tuttavia nella vita si dice che ciò che
non ti uccide ti rafforza quindi magari
si riesce a mettersi in mare e può
essere anche che sia così fortunati da
riuscire ad arrivare sull'isola del
tesoro entrare nella camera del tesoro e
vedere abbracciato allo scrigno lo
scheletro di un capitano che è riuscito
ad arrivare della camera ma non a
portarsi fuori il tesoro è morto nella
camera di fatto sono un po quelli quei
geni incompresi che per essere troppo
avanti o sperimentali per i propri tempi
sono stati riconosciuti solo post mortem
un esempio museo ski l'autore delle
musiche che teutonico sta eseguendo
nell'avanzamento di andrea mestieri o
anche il grande van gogh che è morto
dopo aver venduto soltanto un quadro
quindi senza essere minimamente
consapevole di ciò che il futuro e i
posteri gli avrebbero tributato quindi
come è stato e capendo forse il percorso
della sperimentazione è un mare quasi
sempre in burrasca abbiamo parlato di
pirati ammutinamenti scogli scheletri e
qualcuno di voi lecitamente potrebbe
chiedersi ma cosa ti spinge comunque
metterti in discussione in acque così
pericolose e forse l'idea del tesoro e
l'idea del tesoro inteso anche come idea
che ti può portare soldi insomma
beh sicuramente arricchirsi può essere
un qualcosa che ti spinge fuori di casa
tuttavia se uno coinvolge le sue
aspettative soltanto sull'arricchimento
è solo sul tesoro
beh se il tesoro non lo porti a casa o
comunque ti delude te ne torni a casa
effettivamente con niente in mano
se invece le aspettative thule rivolti
verso il viaggio che ti porterà al
tesoro
anche se il tesoro non lo prendi ten e
core torni a casa con uno scrigno
prezioso e quello delle esperienze di
vita dei ricordi perché se noi siamo ciò
che ricordiamo di essere allora una vita
fatta di esperienze bellissime di
bellezza stessa ricordi surreali beh
allora sarà una ri una vita inferiore
più longeva e poi voglio dire non è che
sempre può andare male è talvolta può
capitare anche di essere protagonisti di
imprese bellissime come ad esempio
registrare gli strumenti ideati da
leonardo da vinci con gli strumenti
moderni per la prima volta oppure due
robot in un album musicale 1
il robot più evoluto al mondo aicab
dell'istituto italiano di tecnologia a
sensori pelle 4mila e sensori pelle ai
sensi e l'altro teutonico questo
bellissimo robot dagli occhioni azzurri
che sta suonando il piano scusa a marco
se permetti preferirei presentarmi da
solo ma cos'è la macchina che si ribella
all'uomo
beh se però pensi di poterti presentare
da solo
buonasera tote sono teutonico robot
pianista progettato e realizzato a imola
da matteo suzie
nell'attuale versione dispongo di 53 di
tra azionate da elettromagnetiche mi
consentono di regolare più o meno forte
la pressione sui tasti sono in grado di
leggere gli spartiti in formato digitale
e posso suonare qualsiasi genere
musicale
la cosa che mi diverte di più a cantare
se lo gradisce posso che aperti un brano
del mio cantante preferito
il carino vuole cantare più bravo certo
theo canta qualsiasi brano del mio
repertorio è molto divertente
no caro marco il mio cantante preferito
è franco battiato ascolta questo cerco
un centro di gravità permanente che non
mi faccio mai cambiare idea sulle cose
sulla gente avrei bisogno di un centro
di gravità permanente che mi faccia mai
cambiare idea
ma sulle cose
questo
[Musica]
teutonico